por aquí tengo la gráfica de dos
funciones en rojo tengo a fx y en azul
tengo a gd x c x
y lo que quiero hacer es encontrar
alguna relación entre fx y gx así que lo
primero que voy a hacer es pararme en
algún punto de la gráfica por ejemplo en
este vértice y noto que al menos en ese
punto la distancia vertical entre eje x
y fx es 1 g de 2 parece ser igual a efe
de dos más uno es más voy a notar eso
gd 2
es igual a efe dedos
+ 1 y en realidad esto es cierto ajena
mente a qué punto tome por ejemplo aquí
está f 4 y g de 4 está precisamente una
unidad hacia arriba
aquí está f 6 hija de 6 está una unidad
hacia arriba así que a pesar de que las
gráficas parecen acercarse y de hecho si
buscas la distancia mínima entre las dos
gráficas si se están acercando pero la
distancia vertical entre dos valores de
fx y gtx siempre será 1
siempre es uno así que puede escribir
qué
gx
es igual
efe de x + 1
g x es igual a efe x1 hagamos otro
ejemplo de nuevo aquí tengo fx en rojo y
gx en azul pero ahora si me paro en
cualquier punto por ejemplo aquí en
menos 4 la diferencia es que quede x
parece ser dos unidades menos que fx y
ese cierto no importa donde me pare aquí
también la diferencia de dos unidades y
acá también la diferencia de dos
unidades por lo tanto en este caso
gx gx es igual
efe de x ahora no vaya a sumar sino
restar menos 2 la gráfica de gx está
abajo de la de fx veamos más ejemplos
de nuevo tengo a fx en rojo fx y gx en
azul x bien podría tomarme cualquier
punto por ejemplo podría tomarme este y
veamos este punto de aquí es el menos 3
así que este punto es el menos 3 coma
efe de menos 3 s es este punto aquí
y vemos que el valor de g x que es igual
a efe m3
pues es estoy aquí que es precisamente g
de menos 1 déjenme lo noto
tengo que quede menos uno es igual a efe
de menos tres
efe de menos tres y tomemos otro valor
por ejemplo tomemos el valor de g 00
está por aquí
efe toma el mismo valor en este punto
aquí que es precisamente efe de menos
dos así que
000 es igual a efe de menos 2
efe de menos 2
tomemos otro valor tomemos por ejemplo
aquí g de 1 cuánto tiene que valer el
argumento de f para que coincidan pues
efe toma ese valor precisamente en menos
1 es decir
g de uno es igual a efe
de -1 y creo que ustedes ya ven el
patrón para cada argumento que toma g
efe toma el mismo valor en el argumento
que esta dos unidades atrás toma el
valor en el argumento menos 2 entonces
podría podría decir que gdx cbx es igual
a igual a efe de x menos 2 noten que
aquí estoy moviendo el argumento x menos
2 es en donde voy a evaluar a efe
y digo que eso es precisamente la
relación que hay entre estas dos
funciones y algo que es un poco contra
intuitivo es que si considero x menos
dos móvil la gráfica de g o esto me
desplazo la gráfica de s hacia la
derecha que con relación a efe está
desplazado a la derecha y es un poco
contra intuitivo si no hicieron todo
esto si hubiera sumado el 2 en vez de
restar lo entonces la gráfica de g
estaría desplazada hacia la izquierda de
la gráfica df de x
pero bueno hagamos otro ejemplo este un
último ejemplo se ve más locochón de
nuevo tengo aquí de x y f de x pero
ahora parece que quede x es algo así
como el reflejo de fx a través del eje x
sólo que está un poco más aplanada la
gráfica así que probar en la siguiente
estrategia voy a reflejar la gráfica eje
x a través del eje x y si hago eso aquí
en -8 la gráfica eje x está en menos 2
pasa por él
por aquí parece que vale menos uno así
que por aquí pasaría por el 1
y aquí en 4 vale menos 3 y medio así que
en 4 voy a ponerla en 3 en medio de modo
que la gráfica reflejada se vería algo
así
bueno quizás esto no se vea muy exacto
pero ustedes me entienden la idea ahora
bien que sucede esta gráfica de aquí
quién es esto que acabo de trazar pues
esto es menos g de x para cada punto me
da menos el valor de g de x así que éste
es menos gx pero aún así no alcanzo fx
de hecho parece que para cada punto f x
está tres veces más alto por ejemplo
aquí la función menos que de x en menos
8 vale 2 pero tenía que haber llegado a
aquí vale 1 pero tenía que haber llegado
a 3 acá vale algo así como 3 y medio
pero tendría que haber llegado muchísimo
más alto así que en todos lados parece
que tengo que multiplicar por un factor
de 3 entonces voy a escribir esto como
sigue
fx va a ser igual
tres veces tres veces quien pues estaba
partiendo de menos gx no deje de equis
sino del reflejo de menos gx entonces es
tres veces menos gdx o escrito de otro
modo fx es igual a menos tres veces que
de x también podría despejar ag x de
aquí y escribir esto como si multiplico
todo esto por menos un tercio obtengo gx
es igual a menos un tercio
d efe
de x